it's been 84 years since gurmann was
defeated it was a long journey of many
rating are you kidding me many tears
many lovers but Hawaii certain has
retired
don't die now
we love with his wife his pesky children
thrive friend that for what that [ __ ]
I'm dead
oh my god suck a dick
and to get the girl but you access
blood-borne DLC there was a long list of
things to do first you had to beat the
whole goddamn game are you [ __ ]
kidding me
second of all he had to replay until the
point of this boss many haters stood
inputs way but that one out stuff in the
first boss weaker Emilia this is gonna
be so easy
I must slap that vote oh god now out
Jesus
okay you need to stop hitting me I'd
like I could have gone better how easy
Jesus Christ I dated first before but
this is a new step stop trying to hit me
ow did I just in stick insta kill a man
not on my watch not on my watch
shoot again dammit [ __ ] are you kidding
me [ __ ] [ __ ] healed
oh god please no no
easy-peasy
good job heads it data can you please
sign my autograph man please sign my
autograph get the eye of blood-drunk
from a messenger this is it
there we go
step 4 go out sign on a walk and nothing
bad will happen I promise
well I love walks so cozy outside I love
the outside
hey there babe jesus [ __ ] christ
please don't hurt me huh we did it we
unlocked the deal seats so it's been
very much recommended that you don't
play the DLC on your ng+ playthrough
unless your level hundred at least we're
level 77 let me just point that out I
heard that the DLC is extremely
difficult what a bunch of whiney babies
oh wow this looks so cool oh they have
[ __ ] whips now ow
now I'm not gonna die from the first
[ __ ] enemy okay I might actually do
that what a [ __ ] [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] what an [ __ ] [ __ ] me but this
guy's just here to greet me - the deal
sieve-like hey welcome [ __ ] ass
welcome what is going on
are they with me or against me I don't
understand I'm just gonna chill down
here oh the big guy one [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] another fight this oh god oh
my [ __ ] [ __ ] face dick that ball
looks very suspicious Oh God
rah ha ha never trust balls ladies
am I seriously expected to defeat that
giant Santa Claus Plan B Plan B [ __ ]
Santa Claus [ __ ] Santa Claus everyone
okay what what is happening I don't know
what this is
vicar is that you Emilia well I'm gonna
take this thank you [ __ ] no God now I'm
triumph Santa's got me cornered don't
worry Santa is really bad Harry okay
Santa don't be scared sandy
you be scared and go fist my daddy I'm
so sorry Santa I'm so sorry worth it ooh
I smell it oh oh I smell a trap good
barrels huh jab like you scared me mmm
creepy [ __ ] super barrels
Oh God hey Gramps hey Gramps wake up get
your drop goddamnit Gramps always drinks
too much ooh ah I'm fine the [ __ ] is
this
ah oh my god that's bloody disgusting
mate hop that
Oh God adjust the [ __ ] back damage
any [ __ ] shoots me oh I'm not a fan
of this oh okay that was one oh [ __ ]
this place
Oh what [ __ ] okay you want to play
that game
yes oh god no oh god no oh god no plan B
plan B M [ __ ] me
hey cry oh god they're moving oh that's
excite let's go in here yep
this looks totally safe feel very safe
here oh it smells like a really bad pus
by doesn't it oh god okay here we go hi
guys
well
give it up Miley
this is gonna be kinky you know this is
gonna be kinky
ah
you might want to get that thing on your
neck checked out man all right we're
going to go with the same tactic as
always run towards - Oh God
run towards them and slack are you
[ __ ] kidding me
I'm alive I'm alive not anymore
anymore oh you thought you thought I was
done
you thought I will give up
haters never quit and quitters never
hate
[ __ ] yeah this is going to be easy
my wife I like to smack that booty like
I do here and these are our baby
children there would be no food unless I
go so [ __ ] tired